what do you like better china or mexico  chinese  are you mexican nope i'm chinese  [Laughter]  he got that steve confidence he just put  a whole country in the garbage he just  said everyone can relax  did you know you're mexican did you know  that  you know you're mexican mom  yes you're mexican  but you speak spanish  that wasn't your budgie  dude bart what are you teaching this guy  you told him that that's a butt cheek i  don't know this guy's a mind of his own  man is it over for us is this the last  episode of jk probably nope you're a  snack man oh we're stuck we're stuck  here  we're stuck here that's what he said  we're stuck here i thought he said nope  you're a snackman